[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
May 9th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
self-checkout machines have streamlined
the process for a lot of Shoppers to pay
for their items and be on their way Wall
Street Journal reporter Rachel wolf is
with us to discuss how some of those
checkout machines are now asking for
tips and stopping Shoppers in their
tracks
so Rachel is this something new and how
much in tips or self-checkout machines
asking for this is very new
self-checkout is new so the idea of tips
at self-checkout is even newer and
self-checkout machines are asking for
this standard 15 20 25
it is really shocking to customers who
say they don't know what to do alright
but we normally see a range of tip
options when you're actually tipping on
service but the machine usually just
provides one level of service is that
confusing people people are definitely
confused why a machine should get a tip
the companies for their parts say that
the tips still go to the employees who
are stocking the shelves or doing the
other things to make it possible at
restaurants it's going to the cooks so
it's not just going to the machines for
the companies that I spoke to though
some of the labor experts that I
interviewed worried that because there
aren't the same protections for tipped
robot as there are for tipped employees
that companies could use this as a way
not to give tips to employees oh so
there could be a bit of an undercurrent
here it's possible tips legally have to
go to an employee things that are
classified as a tip on your check there
are laws that save those wages need to
go to employees there have been plenty
of lawsuits when companies have not
followed those laws and this is just
sort of Uncharted Territory so the
experts are divided on how this all
looks and again the companies that I
spoke to did say that the tips go to
employees and what's happening is that
tips are away again some labor Advocates
say for companies to subsidize employee
pay rather than paying them more they're
putting the onus on consumers to bolster
their wages now you spoke with some
Shoppers who've experienced this how's
this going over with them Shoppers are
perplexed
are really angry they say that tipping
is everywhere and they're starting to
get fatigued by seeing so many tip
screens they emphasize that they always
tip for service they recognize how
important tips are to employee pay many
people I spoke to have either worked in
the service industry previously or still
work in the service industry these are
not people who are stingy by any means
they are really skeptical of where these
tips are going and they worry that
companies are using this as like gotcha
tactic it feels like a bit of a scheme
they say how does this fit into the
overall trends of tipping by Shoppers
whether they're tipping a person
directly or tipping a machine
uh a big part of that is the is the
proliferation of those tip screens we
now see everywhere square whose
technology Powers many of those point of
sound machines says tips transactions
were up 17 year over year at full
service restaurants and 16 at Quick
Service restaurants in the fourth
quarter of 2022. so we're seeing a big
increase and so far there isn't good
data to suggest that tip fatigue has set
in and people are tipping less it's more
that people are wondering how long they
can keep doing this and you know when
it's going to end now a moment ago you
mentioned that there are laws governing
tipping and they govern tips given to
people is there any word on these laws
having to be revamped and updated
because now there are machines involved
I don't think that's something that has
made it into the legal sphere as of yet
I think it's brand new is there any
concern that the machines asking for
tips could rub Shoppers the wrong way to
the point where it might affect their
tipping decision in other scenarios the
consumers I spoke to said that seeing a
tip at self-checkout doesn't necessarily
make them less likely to tip humans in
the future but they are wondering when
it'll end and what the point of a tip
even is anymore when you're being asked
for tips for absolutely everything
including for checking yourself out so
yes and no again the consumers I spoke
to weren't like screw this I'm not
tipping anymore these are really
generous people who think a lot about
tipping they're very moral and they're
really twisted up in knots over this
question of do you tip at self-checkout
a lot of the people I spoke to did still
tip which was really interesting that's
Wall Street Journal reporter Rachel wolf
and that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]